finally we have it
the godzilla versus kong trailer and i
must say legendary and warner bros
almost didn't want us to see what is to
come
i think maybe let us all remember that
this day the 24th of january as the day
we finally get to see the trailer of the
most epic movie of this century
so let us break it down part by part
what has been shown to us before that
let us just agree that it was super
awesome and along with the jesus we are
now ready again energized for the
upcoming battle
of course the suspense was a bit too
much and quite a number of us have
started to lose interest and patience
it was the opposite path that they have
taken and if you remember kftm it was
just a little too much and we could
almost predict the movie itself
so let's get to it so at first we see a
city under attack
which city we do not know but the blast
seems to affect a lot of buildings
around it
and the people are taking shelter in
underground metro stations
and in here we hear the words it's our
only chance
and right after that we see a carrier
battle group carrying the unconscious
gong on top of the biggest ship
that they have there which surprisingly
isn't the aircraft carrier but looks to
be an oil tanker
a big one at that bigger than the gerald
r4 carrier
in the tankier kong looks to be fully
sedated and snoring his way to kingdom
gong
and as we can see here his neck his legs
and his arms have been chained with
super heavy chains
and how he got himself into this mess is
unknown but since later on in the
trailer
it is said that he cares for a human
child and has in a way
promised to take care of her all we can
almost see a slight resemblance
to the original kong movies in which he
was love struck with anne darrow
up to a point where he got knocked off
with chloroform and selective drugs
which made it possible for humans to
ensnare him and chain him up for the
transportation into the mainland
in the next scene we see kong looking
around
almost with curiosity at the chains that
bind him to the ship
it was almost as if he was okay with it
and was voluntarily allowing himself to
be chained up
there were no monarch armed guards or
military personnel
that were alongside him just in case
things go sour
and in that scene we hear the words that
said we need kong
the world needs him to stop what's
coming then fades out with a scene of
the military jet fighters escorting the
convoy of ships that were transporting
the giant ape
then we get to the part where it was
laid out that kong is in fact in a deep
connection with a human child
maybe a kid from the eewee natives of
skull island
and as you can see she can only
communicate with sign language which
means she was deaf
or in a way like the eewee natives not
capable of speaking
it is said that this child is the only
one that he communicates with
and the person knew that they had a bond
since she had nowhere to go
therefore even the person there she made
a promise to protect her which was
similar to kong in some way
as they could see kong did the same
thing he was a giant silent guardian of
the human child
then finally we see some action in the
trailer
as both the eewee child and most
probably an admiral of the battle fleet
census godzilla was on the way to
intercept kong
of which the next scene was shown as
godzilla swims
at full speed towards a destroy warship
his super durable
and hard dorsal plates were too much
against the armored hull of a united
states warship
it is seen that he slices the big ship
in half and what ensues is a big
explosion in which
in a way shows how useless human
technology is against a super life form
that has
millions of years behind him of
evolution to help it
into perfection then immediately jet
fighters are seen firing missiles at the
g-man
but to no damage at all then
surprisingly godzilla
can actually take out jet fighters with
his tail then we see the human
characters all
in shock as if it was unbelievable that
godzilla was able to take down all their
defense weapons
and without even breaking sweat they
were also scared in a way that the most
powerful force on the planet was hostile
towards them
which only means that they were helpless
and useless against such odds
even gong with all his might was seen in
a state of awe and what was coming
towards him
it was a look reminiscent of i should
have stayed at home
i'm sorry ma then we get to the scene
where we have already seen
the one where kong fishes godzilla out
of the sea with a
bait of ape humor and wit at this time
we hear the words
it's godzilla as if we needed to be sure
that the g-man was the g-man
then a prolonged clip of godzilla
actually trying to climb on top of the
ship which surprisingly is seen as the
aircraft carrier
this means one thing that the ship that
was carrying kong was
originally shown to be something like an
oil tanker and now it's a warship
this means that there is more to this
bell than what meets the eye
core might have gone overboard and was
nearly killed by godzilla until he got
into the next biggest ship
it is here that we see the punch
actually connecting with the g-man's
face
which wasn't a knockout punch we could
still see godzilla reeling away
from the head only to try and face his
opponent again
as if nothing ever happened kong with
his width used his advantage of being on
the ship
longer actually used his whole body to
push godzilla back into the sea again
there we could see that the military was
no doubtedly siding with kong and was
firing depth charges that godzilla who
was
now underwater it was for naught as we
can see the g-man quickly maneuver
himself and fire an atomic blast
straight at the
ship dissecting it in half and forcing
corn to jump into the ocean
this makes you wonder how kong could
have survived being underwater with the
king of the oceans
a super species poseidon in pursuit of
him
ok so in the next scene we could see
godzilla roaring in the middle of what
seems to be hong kong china
the buildings and high rise with neon
lights outlining their sights
godzilla seems to be in good scaling as
he is seen not towering
the cityscape in which many buildings
were actually in the thousand feet range
and surprisingly godzilla is seen
blasting the landscape with the
smithereens with his iconic blue flame
mark russell then makes an appearance
stating that godzilla is out there and
he is hurting people and we do not know
why
which we might think that mechagodzilla
was in fact responsible for the
political
u-turn on godzilla and the attacks on
cities were in fact
orchestrated by the apex organization in
charge
of cybernetics and robotics so in the
map we could see that the apex
facilities were targeted out
specifically by the g-man
and that there were many casualties
following the attack which leads the u.n
to veto against godzilla
therefore declaring war upon the titan
and on the meantime madison russell
reprising her role
tries to figure out the exact reason as
to why godzilla was behaving
different than usual stating that there
is something provoking him
that we are not seeing here which means
that there are unknown forces trying to
draw out a battle
a conflict between the two tyrann score
and godzilla in which the final outcome
whatever may be
would be beneficial for it
then we travel back into the past in
which a new character eileen andrews
played by rebecca hall
says that the myths are real and there
was a war a war between the titans in
which the only ones surviving were these
two
and they are the only ones standing
could this be adhering to a past major
conflict before the perez and era
of that this war happened between the
events of kotm
and gbk that we'll have to find out and
see
and while stating that the scenes were
depicting what could have
only been the hollow earth as the
mountain ranges in the distance were
inverted
and here we could finally see the nuzuki
or the warbats in a fight with kong
these warbats were very long in fact
double their triple
the height of kong in the end the scenes
take us back to the ultimate duel
between godzilla and kong
with kong holding the balance which he
might have found or crusted under the
hollow earth
using a dorsal plate of godzilla or one
of the g-man's ancestors
we do not know we could see that kong's
advantage was on dry land
where he was in a way faster and more
agile than godzilla
with and with the battle axe he could
deflect and actually absorb godzilla's
atomic breath
making him the only talent to ever have
the ability to do so
therefore evening the odds against him
so yeah
that's about it god damn the trailer was
fun and it was worth the wait
now we only have to look forward to the
movie
and so with that we come to the end of
this trailer break down and we will come
back to a few more points
that we have discussed and take the
descriptive path and in-depth look into
them
so subscribe for more videos about the
monsterverse and godzilla vscom videos
so yeah do hit that like button for
support and also smash that notification
bell for regular updates
take care fam